-Our next guest
has a new stand-up special,
"Look At You,"
streaming now on Netflix.
Please welcome the very funny
Taylor Tomlinson.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Thank you so much!
Oh, my God.
It's so good to be here.
It has been
a rough couple of years.
I got bangs at one point.
Things got dark.
[ Laughter ]
I didn't want bangs.
I just needed people
to check on me, and --
[ Laughter ]
It works, by the way.
You post a selfie in bangs,
everybody's like, "Fire emoji.
You go, girl!"
Then they text you, like,
"You okay?"
[ Laughter ]
Here's what I did.
I got bangs,
and then two days later, I did
mushrooms for the first time.
[ Laughter ]
And as soon
as I did those mushrooms,
I was like, "I should've
done these first."
[ Laughter ]
Probably wouldn't have gotten
these bangs
if I forgave myself, huh?
But you know what?
Having bangs feels exactly like
being on mushrooms.
The whole time, you're just
looking at your friends like,
"Do I look weird?"
[ Laughter ]
"You guys would tell me
if I looked weird, right?"
[ Laughter ]
They're like, "Don't tell her.
She'll freak out."
[ Laughter ]
I finally
found an anti-depressant
that works for me,
which is great.
A lot of my friends
scared me by getting on them.
I had a lot of friends
who were like,
"I tried to get
on anti-depressants.
I just didn't like
how I felt on them.
I didn't
feel like myself on them."
And now that I'm on them,
I'm like "Yeah, me neither.
It's the best!"
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Right?
And I do feel like myself.
I just feel like
now someone's sitting on me,
going, "Shh!
Stop talking.
We are trying to help you.
You will ruin everything.
Go to sleep.
Choose a different adventure."
[ Laughter ]
I didn't know anti-depressants
were an option
when I was growing up.
When I was in high school,
I was like,
"Dad, I think I'm depressed,"
and he was like,
"You just need some protein.
Get a scoop of peanut butter."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, there's a lot of
conservative dads out there
just white-knuckling it
through life right now,
clinging to a jar of chunky Jif
like it's the answer.
Just a buoy in the storm.
Like, "It'll pass!"
[ Laughter ]
The only mental-health advice
my dad ever gave me is,
I was having panic attacks
in high school,
and I didn't know
what they were, and I was like,
"I don't know what to do
when I feel like this.
I don't know what to do.
I don't know what to do."
And he goes, "All right.
All I can tell you is that
when you feel like this,
get as far away from the people
you care about as possible."
[ Laughter ]
"Until you feel different."
Which is advice
you give a werewolf.
Like...
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Just run into the woods till
you're not a monster anymore.
Don't let them see you change.
They won't accept you
for what you truly are."
I did read something recently
that said
if you had
a difficult childhood,
you need to learn how to parent
yourself as an adult.
So I've been trying to do that.
I've been trying
to parent myself.
But I kind of feel like
I got pregnant with me
in high school and, uh...
[ Laughter ]
...I was not ready
for this responsibility.
Not supposed to shake me.
Just found that out.
[ Laughter ]
And now every day,
I wake up totally overwhelmed.
Just like, "Okay.
If I let you watch TikTok
on my phone for 40 minutes,
will you please stop crying?"
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
All my friends are like,
"Are you okay?"
I'm like,
"No, I think I have colic.
I kept me up all night."
[ Laughter ]
Lot of my friends
are settling down.
Some of them are just settling,
end of sentence.
[ Laughter ]
You guys have those couples
in your lives?
Yeah.
[ Scattered cheers ]
Yeah, where one person
in the couple is way hotter
and cooler than the other person
in the couple?
I like to call those couples
chocolate-covered raisins.
[ Laughter ]
'Cause they're like, "Sure, you
could put those two together...
If you want."
[ Laughter ]
But every time you see them,
you're like,
"Chocolate, what are you doing?
Like...
[ Laughter ]
Like, you could've been
with anybody.
You could've been with caramel,
you could've been with
marshmallow,
you could've
been with peanut butter,
who I heard cures depression..."
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
"...and you want to be
with a raisin forever?
Like, no offense, raisin.
You're great.
We love you.
Nature's candy -- that's you.
But you belong
with, like, oatmeal.
Like, let's be honest."
[ Laughter ]
Aren't you scared every day
that someone's gonna come along
and suck chocolate
right off of you?
I love doing that joke
because I like to feel
couples in the audience
getting nervous.
Like,
"Am I chocolate or raisin?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
"We're both chocolate,
right, babe?
We're chocolate-covered
chocolate?
We're like the little Lindor
guys in the foil, you know?
I'm the creamy part,
and you're the shell
'cause you're so strong and if
you leave me, I'll be a mess?"
Thank you so much,
"Tonight Show."
I appreciate it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Oh, my gosh!
Didn't see the peanut-butter
callback coming at all!
Taylor Tomlinson!
That is how you do it
right there.
"Look At You"
is streaming now on Netflix.